Robbie when you see a labor of love like
Cody it actually come to life what is
your reaction has it been like four
years since you guys did that for years
right I can still remember rehearsing
the short film on my front lawn you know
right yeah yeah it's great it's it feels
like a long time and no time at all you
know at the same time so many little
milestones along the way shooting in
short film launching the IndieGoGo
campaign hitting our goal in 48 hours
you know front paging reddit with the
short you know shooting first day of
shooting the movie finishing the movie
shoots on the movie like there's it's
just so many different things and it's
been my favorite part of my career and
not just your like IndieGoGo goal in the
two days like we shot well past it yeah
well well well past it yeah two point
four something million dollars which is
I'm I'm just like I'm in awe of the
support from over 27,000 backers and one
of the coolest things was 300 people
paid money to fly to Toronto somewhere
from here but a lot from around the
world flew to Toronto put themselves up
and were extras in the movie that's
amazing yeah so they got to be in it
there so we took them all out to like a
bar that night and took over the
upstairs and just celebrated with them
that's wild so what is the conversation
about the movie become then once you see
oh we hit our milestone no wait a minute
we're getting more oh so how does it
change with you guys to change the film
because do more of a get to do more yeah
I mean this the script didn't change
much yeah we were always going to make
the same movie but the things within the
scenes got a little bigger you know the
action scenes got a little bigger the
visual effects got a little stronger you
know we we thought maybe we would make a
couple million dollar movie and we ended
up making something so much bigger yeah
the crazy thing about the campaign was
IndieGoGo would tell us okay based on
how much you made in your first day this
is what you can expect for your entire
campaign and you know it's supposed to
kind of go like this and then you have a
lull in the middle and then you get a
lot at your last couple
and our campaign just like we kind of
broke IndieGoGo and it I mean it was
just because we have such unbelievable
supporters and backers and fans what
does it say about the potential for
people to make their own stuff if they
just want to get out there and do it I
mean we live at a beautiful time in the
industry or in the world where
everybody's got a camera yeah in their
pocket and everybody has an outlet in
YouTube you know YouTube famous is way
more famous than any other kind of
famous right now yeah but it's nice
because you know it used to be you
needed a friend with the camera you
needed this you needed that now
everyone's got one so you know if you
have friends you can do it you can just
you know try and make something see if
you see if you like it see if it works
for ya
and then not only that for independent
film you've got so many outlets so many
streaming networks for places to go it
used to be such a studio system now you
know everybody can make their own enough
so code eight you've got this like
dystopian near future Yeah right
and it's about superpowers but it's not
just about superpowers like people have
surprised us a bit about the stories we
got the whole idea yeah so the coda
takes place in Lincoln City and in our
world four percent of people are born
with some kind of abnormal ability and a
rate you range from a class one to a
class five class one I mean it's almost
a useless power whereas a class five can
be very dangerous and somewhere along
the way police force got very
militarized and people with power were
marginalized and and it's illegal to use
your power in public they have trouble
getting jobs most of them live under the
poverty line and Lincoln City was this
growing city and and now it's it's it's
kind of this place where people have
powers just trying to get by mm-hmm
where did this story come from is it
something that's just from your head is
it you and Steven is it no Steven I
worked with Jeff Chan who directed the
movie he came up with a story crisp RA
another friend of ours who wrote the
story they were very much the the
captains behind this data and Steven and
I just helped out wherever we could
along the way but you know when we first
started talking
about it we knew we wanted to make
something that we were fans of and that
was in our wheelhouse and we know our
super power type shows but we wanted it
to be you know pretty grounded sci-fi
and with the short film we asked a lot
of questions or we posed a lot of
questions and people argued about them
in the in the comments which is always
fun you know you got people agreeing
with what my character did and some
people disagreement we didn't want to
live in this world of and right and
wrong and black and white because that's
not the real world there's a lot of gray
area and and people feel different ways
about different things and that's what
we wanted to build this movie yeah you
know as adults we were watching
superhero content shows and movies we
can see them like the powers and the
people that powers as analogues for
things that are going on in the world
today certainly this movie represents
that that's a huge part of what this
story is about yeah we didn't want to
preach anything we didn't know we don't
want anything to be too heavy-handed and
above all else our first job is to
entertain people know if you're gonna
pay to rent or buy the movie you got to
be entertained yeah but at the same time
we wanted to have substance and you know
in this world this marginalized
marginalization of people with powers is
a lot like what's happening around the
world you know not necessarily people
with powers but you know people just a
lot of people around the role and
there's and there's a lot of problems
and we didn't we didn't want to try and
steer anybody in any directions but we
wanted people to talk about it and think
about it and maybe walk out of the movie
thinking about things they wouldn't
normally think about because it was
wrapped in a cool sci-fi package sure
they're understand yeah you know can you
think back to when you were a kid
playing superheroes did have a go - yeah
for sure I love Batman yeah between he
knew Steven who was Batman who's Robin I
make Superman fan oh yeah yeah okay
Steve's a big big Superman fan but I
know he also likes to play villains but
when we were kids we were you know
there's a seven year age gap so there
wasn't a whole lot of like you know
pretending to be Batman and super get
some video games and then and then we
got much
buzzer when we were older yeah so onset
being that he is like the villain but he
takes on a harder role for sure in this
film then then your character does but
wasn't like working together was it also
was it like a nice opportunity to
actually create something together in
this space that you love the powers of
superheroes kind of like shackles off
yeah I mean it was just cool to work
together yeah it just as a whole you
know getting to to spend five or six
weeks together because he's been
shooting in Vancouver I've been living
in LA you know we see each other for
occasional like family dinners or stuff
but yeah you know for this to get to
hang out for six weeks work opposite
each other really see how the other
person does work and since it was our
own project we got to you know we were
own boss we got to mold the scenes and
find them and and shape them into
something that we were proud of mm-hmm
do you see a future for these characters
and this story it doesn't I mean the
movie doesn't necessarily go it's open
let's do more but there's there's a rich
world here that can be explored I agree
you know a lot of this was world
building and and and just introducing
everybody to Lincoln City we would love
to do more I guess it'll depend on how
this week and weekend goes yeah get that
next IndieGoGo campaign goes yeah so yes
congratulations are in order not just
for this film but you've had a new
member of the family recently yes so
September September 12 yeah he's amazing
he's huge poor wife he's enormous
do you know a photographer had like
where he was nine pounds even crazy yeah
but how the crazy thing is is he's just
continued to like just grow
off-the-charts I don't know where he my
dad was like six one and a half maybe
his tallest this kid is he's if he
continued as a girl like this is going
to be freakishly large so I don't know
if it's from Italia's side or something
but he's amazing he's really sweet so
you're like going to Dad's gym every day
now he's just picking up the kid like we
walk him around occasionally and we're
both like
what is happening here like this this
little tank he's great he's so great
they say there are very few things in
the world that change you as much as
becoming a parent it is a massive
perspective shift yeah best way I can
put it leading up to it I've never hung
out with like babies for very long sure
and I was like I have what am I gonna do
right and then you know it doesn't feel
real until for me it didn't feel real
until he was in the world and all of a
sudden it was very real and it just
shifts your perspective to everything
that seemed so important and and and
mattered so much still matters but your
child is like head and shoulders above
that did you sleep at all and the first
like three four days the first night he
slept great it really really what's
happening here but something we thought
we were and then second night was knodel
but because he's so big
he's he sleeps well he eats well he
sleeps well he just eats and sleeps and
craps this is this is life and living
the dreams what a baby supposedly no
clean rock laughter you're like when I
grow up I want to get you
[Laughter]